[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast
thank you for joining us this morning
millions of us are set to enjoy a taste
of freedom after months of lockdown
and what seems like even more months of
cold wet miserable
weather the sun is out for the bank
holiday the met office is predicting
what could be the hottest day of the
year with temperatures of 25 degrees
celsius in some parts of the country
but scientists are urging people to be
sensible
with one member of the government's
advisory group warning that the uk is on
a knife edge with cases of the
coronavirus
rising again insurmount rashid reports
now from blackpool
this seaside town has missed not just
the people
but the sun too this weekend
it got it all with the theme park pack
and some of the warmest weather of the
year so far we've heard how busy it is
on the prom
loads of people about you know a seaside
resort should have people enjoying
themselves having ice creams on the
beach all of that kind of stuff just to
see that back
and everything that that supports with
the economy in the town
the employment in the town all of those
things really really important it's
important to have some importance to the
wider resort
[Applause]
tourist towns like blackpool have been
economically crushed by the pandemic
but with many people now vaccinated this
long
sunny weekend is a reminder of what
normality looks like
but we aren't fully there yet some of
the country's top scientists
are still urging caution and believe the
next two weeks
are critical we're on a knife edge
we could go either way with this new
variant either um
the new variant could just run away as
it did with the b117 before christmas
um which would be extremely serious and
we would have to
have more restrictions which none of us
want or potentially
it could be contained but that does mean
that everybody needs to be cautious
right now whilst it may look busy
many people here are taking care
like haider and his brother and sisters
they've missed months of fun
so the whole family traveled from
scotland to meet relatives
and take advantage of the weather oh yes
like i said it's just something that we
all needed we all needed the you know
the nice warm weather and uh yeah it
just makes everyone feel a lot more
better to be honest it's good obviously
having just
good quality time with your family that
you missed because you've always seen
the corvette lockdown you just
obviously it's just it's just a good
time and a seaside holiday abroad
still seems far off for this family from
birmingham
so they're here for a staycation it's
been awful for everyone hasn't it
and been just been stuck in the house
the kids have been in the same routines
but it's been really nice to get away
with all the family this weekend
it's amazing it's nice to be back here
and um you know
do stuff there's been like so for so
long you haven't been able to see
anybody
forgot what it's like to be in a pub go
to a football match anything so
it's like a new world again one thing is
clear
no one wants another lockdown but just
because the sun is out
it doesn't mean the virus isn't and this
bank holiday
may play a crucial role in our next
steps to freedom
in saman rashid sky news blackpool
france is tightening its borders to
travelers from britain as fears continue
to grow around the spread of the india
coronavirus variant
from today france will only allow eu
nationals and french residents to enter
the country
from britain and those people will need
to have a compelling reason to travel
those who are allowed in will also need
to take a pre-departure covert test and
we'll have to quarantine for seven days
on arrival
well let's have a look at the latest
covert figures for the uk there have
been
3 240 new cases in the latest 24-hour
period
six more deaths have been reported
bringing the total number of deaths
within 28 days of testing
positive to 127
781 meanwhile the vaccine bro lot
another 190
822 people got their first jabs
and 440 435 got the second
shots that means over 25 million people
are now fully vaccinated against the
virus
more than 3 000 former interpreters and
other afghan
nationals who risked their lives to help
british troops in afghanistan
have been offered the chance to resettle
in the uk political correspondent
tomorrow cohen is in westminster this
morning morning tamara how is this going
to work
morning kimberly well essentially
hundreds of former interpreters and
their families are expected to find it
easier
to make new lives in the uk under this
scheme
now british troops ended their combat
operations
in afghanistan back in 2014 but the
defense secretary says that this
reflects the deteriorating security
situation
in the country many former interpreters
have already been targeted
by insurgents and ben wallace says
therefore this is the right thing to do
this is what he told us with the changes
now with with the western powers leaving
afghanistan the threat is increasing and
has increased
uh with targeted attacks against afghans
by the taliban so we think it's the
right thing to do to stand by
these people they they sacrificed a lot
to look after us and now we're going to
do the same
now this follows a long-running campaign
supported by many british soldiers
to help the interpreters come over it
extends an existing policy there are
already over a thousand
former interpreters and families living
in the uk
but under this scheme it won't matter
how long they served
in what capacity and whether they were
employed directly by the mod
or locally they will still get the
chance to apply and there will be no cap
on numbers
the mod will be working with the home
office to help them find accommodation
and get support when they come over
which is expected to start
within weeks and pretty patel the home
secretary also described it as a moral
obligation
to help those who help british forces
okay tamara thank you
two opposition leaders in israel are
joining forces in a deal that could oust
the current prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
the head of the right-wing yamina party
naftali bennett is holding coalition
talks with the main
centrist party after four inconclusive
elections
in just two years mr netanyahu is on
trial for fraud
and fell short of a decisive majority at
a general election in march
he says the proposed deal would weaken
israel
i heard naftali bennett unfortunately he
is again
misleading the public same lies same
empty slogans on hate and division
from someone who gives a hand to hatred
and division
and also someone who was perpetrating
the fraud of the century
there are fears thousands of private
renters in england could be about to
lose their homes
a ban on evictions ends today after
being brought in during the pandemic
joseph roundtree foundation estimates
400 000 people are afraid of being
evicted with many more in arrears
drivers in england and wales could save
about 35 pounds on their insurance
because of new rules on whiplash and
other minor injury accidents
a new online portal portal will help
people make traffic related to injury
claims
below 5000 pounds themselves but it
won't be possible to settle whiplash
cases
without medical evidence we have seen an
increase in the number of claims being
made
as a result of road traffic accidents
sadly a number of them frankly
that have been fraudulent claims and
that's resulted in an increase
in premiums for all of us that's not
good
for road users and it's certainly
not good in terms of the reputation of
the insurance industry
and that's why i think the new online
system dealing with those smaller claims
will help root out fraud and help reduce
premiums for all of us
birmingham becomes a clean air zone from
tomorrow but some businesses
say the timing of the move could kill
off shopping and business areas
polluting cars and vans will be charged
eight pounds to travel into the city
centre and polluting lorries will be
charged 50 pounds
the charges are expected to put off many
people from driving in but some shop
owners
are critical saying it comes as they're
trying to get back on their feet after
the pandemic
sky's becky johnson reports major roads
are the arteries that run
through birmingham the city that was
once the heart of britain's automotive
industry
but now vehicle access to the city
centre will be restricted
as clean air zone charges come into
force
[Applause]
business owners struggling to recover
from the pandemic
fear people simply won't return to the
city centre
the concept of it yes i welcome a
cleaner city
and a cleaner environment the timing of
it is shockingly bad
for the city it is just wrong
to introduce this right now when the
city has been crippled
by a pandemic some argue it'll penalize
the city's poorest
electric vehicles and some newer cleaner
cars will be exempt from the charge
which means people who can't afford to
upgrade will be the ones who have to pay
but evidence shows people on low incomes
who live close to busy roads
are most at risk from air pollution and
with levels dangerously high
the council says the plan will go ahead
time is against us we have to launch
this the reality is in in the city of
birmingham every year
hundreds and hundreds of people are
dying because of illegal and unsafe
levels of air quality
so we've got to get this right
birmingham follows bath which introduced
its clean air
zone earlier this year and with other
cities drawing up plans
there are signs that reducing traffic
may even
benefit businesses there's actually
evidence from the uk and from abroad
that when you pedestrianize the street
or when you reduce
traffic people tend to stay longer just
because it's nicer to be in a street
where
there's no cars for instance and so we
know they also tend to spend more
experts agree that cities will only
thrive if there are better
cheaper convenient alternatives to
driving
make it much easier people to get about
so that the the first option is not the
sort of the car
it's better public transport in the race
to drive
down emissions the challenge for cities
will be cleaning up the air
without suffocating business becky
johnston
sky news birmingham let's have a look at
some of the day's other news now and
almost
200 incidents of so-called upskirting
were reported to police in england and
wales
last year some victims of the offence
where attempts are made to take
sexual pictures without consent were as
young as 14 they were targeted in places
like supermarkets parks and on public
transport
the surge in the number of people who
came forward to volunteer for the nhs
during the pandemic has been hailed as a
positive legacy for the service's future
according to nhs england new data shows
that 436
000 people from the nhs volunteer
responders program
have carried out nearly 2 million tasks
for those who had to stay at home during
the lockdown
the number of age discrimination
complaints to employment tribunals
increased by 74 in the last year
according to new research
rest less which offers advice to over
50s dealt with more than 3 000 cases the
biggest
annual increase of all complaints
south sudan has become the epicenter of
a humanitarian crisis
civil disorder and natural disasters
have thrown the country into chaos
famine and disease is becoming a reality
and against that backdrop
the cut in the uk foreign aid budget is
hitting hard
see if the children's executive director
of policy kirsty mcneill joins me now
good morning kirsty thank you for
talking to us
um your work in south sudan has it been
affected by these cuts to the uk foreign
aid budget it has hugely i'm afraid so
children in south sudan were already
facing
a triple whammy of covert conflict and
climate change
and on top they now face cuts that are
both deep and devastating
our correspondent um was in a place
called pibor
and um he spoke to a rep from
the world food program who said that
they were taking
food from the hungry to give to the
starving that is
incomprehensible is that the kind of
tough decision-making that your people
are having to do on the ground there
yeah so uk food aid to people in south
sudan has already been cut by 30
and we see that in programs right across
the world so
uk humanitarian assistance and that is
the very
life-saving assistance that the public
most wants to see
is being cut and we see this in conflict
zone after conflict zone
so what we're seeing in south sudan is
repeated in places like yemen
in places like syria and it's not just
on hunger
we see cuts affecting things like family
planning on things like
education so that when a woman comes
back to get her implant taken out
there's simply no
doctor or nurse who's able to take it
out that when a child
turns up for its seventh or eighth year
of school there's simply
no teacher there to teach them so that's
the hard reality
of what these aid cuts really mean on
the ground
so people will die will they children
will die
because of these aid cuts undoubtedly so
we already have 34 million people
globally one step
away from famine even before coronavirus
even before the cuts global hunger
levels were
at record level so it's inconceivable
that you can take this amount of money
out of the global system
and not have it immediately lead i'm
afraid to the deaths of children
as someone who works for save the
children as a humanitarian a global
humanitarian worker how do you reconcile
that reality with dominic raab
saying the government is looking to
provide quote
value for tax payers in places like
south sudan
well whenever we speak to the british
public about what they want to see
their generosity is unparalleled
british public want their taxes spent on
saving
and changing children's lives and that's
what our life-changing
life-saving humanitarian assistance does
around the world and that's why when our
chancellor richie sunnac meets his
counterparts on friday
and when boris johnson meets his
counterparts at the g7 group in cornwall
in two weeks time
we'll be saying actually here's a plea
from the hungry children of the world
to reverse course it isn't too late
these aid cuts
can be reversed lives can be saved but
it will require leadership
from both rishi sunak and boris johnson
um let's look at south sudan in
particular
what is the government there doing about
the fact that there is
well they're on the brink of a famine
these are its people
so undoubtedly responsibility primarily
for people in any place would rest with
state
but to be clear in south sudan we
already had a very fragile
situation with a conflict that is not of
children's making
then on top you see the effects of
climate change
with new droughts and food insecurity
and then on top of that
comes this devastating pandemic and
we've seen even in a state as well
functioning and as rich as the uk
that the effects of a pandemic can be
devastating so imagine what it's like
as a family trying to survive against a
backdrop of not just covet
not just climate change but a conflict
and war on top
okay kirsty thank you for talking to us
now he's been hailed as the greatest
marathon runner of the modern era but
even for elliot the plan to run a sub
two-hour marathon
was an ambitious one sky news was there
on the day the quiet kenyan took on his
biggest challenge
now in our new podcast series storycast
21 we
relive the highs and lows of that
momentous day
my name is eliot i'm a marathon runner
i was born on 5th november 1984 in kenya
i'm andy brady i'm a sky news
correspondent and in my spare time i'm
an amateur
marathon runner kipchoga to me until i
met him
had always been this kind of rock star
of running
he was running his whole life he'd run
to school he'd run home from school
and then he would run off and sell dairy
milk
to keep the family finances going when i
was a boy i
really i was really running fast and i
always imagined
among the top in running so i think i
enjoyed running
from the beginning because i want to
inspire people
scientists have been looking at the
running data of marathons for decades
and it was their view that it could take
50 years before we'd see a human
if ever go under two hours
a couple of years before we met he had
tried to break two hours in monza
i i missed about 25 seconds i said to
him will you try again and he goes it
will be my dream to try again
i don't believe in limitations i always
say non-human is limited
eliot kipchoge will set out to make
history today
hoping to become the first person in
history
to run a marathon in under two hours
and to hear how he got on you can listen
to this week's episode of storycast21
it's available now on the sky news app
and obviously wherever you get your
podcasts
time for the weather now joe is with us
hot but how hot joe
how hot indeed how hot uh well we're all
looking at that because yesterday we
managed 24 degrees celsius
that's 75 degrees fahrenheit but the
record so far this year was set on the
31st of march at 24.5 so for this to be
the warmest day of the year
and of course it being the last day of
spring we need to get higher than that
24.5 so we'll be watching watching
throughout the day
and there was a fairly good chance that
we'll see a 25 tomorrow first day of
summer
and the following day well it could be
warmer still all the details coming up
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you i will
say before we start but this fine
weather is down to high pressure
which is uh really situated over the
north sea in scandinavia
and it's starting to move its way
eastwards and as it does so that's going
to allow this uh cloud and rain
to uh brush in and out of western parts
of ireland
and by the middle of the week we will
see a breakdown in the weather it'll be
thundery showers coming up from the
southwest so
enjoy the heat and the sunshine whilst
we've got it and please do remember that
the sun is very strong at this time of
year
even if we have only really seen it just
for the first time
very high uv levels don't go out there
and get burnt so for today then
still rather gray through many central
areas and down towards the south
that's low cloud it's going to burn its
way off elsewhere where the skies have
been clear overnight we've had mist and
fog
and some of that quite dense and again
that's going to
burn off and the sun is strong at this
time of year so it should go quite
rapidly
so taking a look at the temperatures
then uh when we get some sunshine
temperatures
widely 20 to 23 degrees celsius for much
of england and wales we could see a 24
possibly hopefully even a 25
northwestern parts of scotland
was warmest yesterday so there's a fair
chance they're going to be one of the
warmest places today as well
a little bit of fair weather cloud
bubbling up and an outside chance later
on of seeing one or two showers
over western parts of scotland also
northern ireland
now the other fly in the ointment is
this area of uh really slack air in the
north sea it's bringing
some rather misty murky conditions to
eastern coasts
it did the same thing yesterday and
where it lingered temperatures no better
than eight
or nine degrees celsius and obviously
very gray pretty dismal drab conditions
and we'll see the same today some parts
of these eastern coast will stay very
gray
very dull throughout and that's down to
the wind coming from an easterly
direction
so for ireland central and eastern parts
having a nice day with some sunshine out
towards the west there's a good deal of
cloud
and some patchy rain around as well so
as we go into this evening and overnight
again mixed amounts of cloud out towards
the west
some low cloud coming back into
yorkshire and lincolnshire clear skies
elsewhere so the risk of some
mist and fog forming just as we've seen
overnight and then through the course of
tuesday
it'll be that burn back situation once
again
it'll probably be northeastern coast
that see that cloud hanging around
and we're looking at temperatures as i
say 24 25 possibly even a 26 somewhere
that's around 79 degrees fahrenheit and
then of course as we go into wednesday
this is when we start to see these
thundery showers making their way from
the southwest into devon and cornwall
southern parts of ireland and then it'll
work its way northwards through the
course of the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
birmingham is a city that was
transformed by the motor car
its city engineer sir herbert monzini
famously declared that there was little
worth preserving
and set about pulling down its historic
victorian buildings
to accommodate highways and car parks
but from tomorrow
england's second city will become a
clean air zone with councillors
trying to turn back its recent history
and push cars
back out of the center zongo she a
professor in atmospheric science at the
university of birmingham
joins me now thank you so much for
joining us this morning good morning to
you how bad is the air in the city
that they want to get rid of all these
polluting cars
uh thank you good morning and so the
pollution
in birmingham is primarily the problem
of what we call larceny dioxide
particularly in the city center so
there's a legal image which is something
like a 40 microgram per cubic meter
on earlier average basis now it is
predicted that
the city center will not be able to meet
that legal limit
and that is really the causing the legal
problems
but not only in latin dark side we also
have
pm 2.5 it's the fine particles
that penetrates into human lands and
causing
long-term health problems
so are there many health problems
because of pollution in birmingham
it is predicted that about a thousand
premature death every year because of
air pollution in birmingham
and of course that is only the extreme
cases you're talking about
a lot of lower grade air pollution
problems for example you know
people with asthma or with copd
and they could really be seriously
affected by air pollution
and that could cause more people going
to hospital more people
are have to have cares more lost
productivity and cause huge losses to
economy so in terms of the pollution
levels
bank banning the most polluting vehicles
from the center
what effect is that going to happen how
long will it take
for there to be in effect now um in
terms of the
effect we would um predict that
the emissions of pollution will be
reduced
in a city center and that would
eventually
translate into uh improvement in air
quality in the city center
but because of the meteorology might
change we can't
see that immediately we might not be
able to see that immediately
but we will see that hopefully in the
longer term
i think the other thing to to load is
this is at the moment it's it's you know
you've got clean energy
it's in a city center uh and hopefully
this is going to encourage people
to use more public transport
encourage people to uh
change their their cars to more cleaner
ones
and that in the longer term will bring
the health
benefit to all of us living in
birmingham
just to correct myself they're not
banning them they're going to charge
people i think there's eight pounds for
cars and vans and 50 pounds
for lorries do you think more cities
should be looking to this
um cleaners is one of the instruments
where the government
used to try to limit the um
pollution levels in the what we call hot
spots
um and that you know because the those
hot spots and
break the legal limit and you you know
the government
have the obligations to meet that legal
limit
um clean energy as you said
it's only part of the things that you
can do but there is
a lot more we need to do to improve air
quality
not just a clean air zone okay doctor
must say that garden behind you looks
gorgeous thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you
now for next year wales will become the
first uk nation to make
black history lessons mandatory in the
classroom after the black lives matter
protests and a petition for britain's
colonial past to be taught in school
the devolved government wants children
to become more quote ethical
and informed skies laura bundock has
been to schools in cardiff and the
valleys to hear from students and
teachers about their new curriculum
racism is a huge problem in our world we
need the whales free of racism
i hope from now on every month is black
history month
sometimes the smallest voices pack the
biggest punch
martin luther king inspired our speeches
because his speech was to stop
just one thing in the world just really
inspiring so
everyone's just getting together just to
stop this racism
these pupils are from one of cardiff's
most diverse schools
would you like to tell us about some of
the things that you've been learning
lafayette
um we've been learning about platforms
mata and
how to stop racism and how to be
anti-racist
you've been learning black history here
isn't one lesson
it's part of everything they learn our
children need to see themselves
reflected
in the curriculum we look at our local
history the coal industry world war one
world war
ii how is it that cardiff bay is so
diverse
so through all of that they have a sense
of belonging
but head to the welsh valleys and
there's a very different landscape
here ethnic diversity is low
but it's a large part of kojo hazel's
lessons
george floyd hands up if you heard that
name it's my job really
certainly as a role model um for these
peoples here and to be able to teach
them about what's outside the valley you
know what's
what's in the wider world and give them
a real rounded experience so they can
when they do eventually get to leave
they've got you know much more better
understanding
and for this pe lesson that
understandings all about
black athletes okay bottom right hand
corner
muhammad i enjoyed it
i felt like it brought a new insight to
what is going on
i didn't know who like 80 percent of the
people were
we're in charge of making the world a
nicer place in the future so i think
it's important to the
people of the older generations and show
us how to
make the world a better place
black history will be mandatory in the
new welsh curriculum
none of the other nations have gone this
far
this is just as important to the maths
teacher
as it is to the musical history teacher
professor charlotte williams helped
develop the new curriculum
this is the right of every child in
wales
to have their knowledge base enriched
and expanded
and to be prepared for the global
connectedness of wales
the diversity of wales is woven into its
history
and very soon these stories will be told
in every school
laura bundock sky news cardiff
joe is here with the weather now joe
what a gorgeous day yesterday and it
could be even hotter today
it could indeed temperatures yesterday
24 degrees celsius today
if we get 25 that'll make it the warmest
day of the year so far and rather saves
springs it is the last day of spring
today
the first couple of days the summer are
looking quite good too but then the
middle of the week brings
a thundery breakdown let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
we've still got high pressure dominating
the weather it's
created this easterly flow which is
bringing a lot of low cloud in
across north sea coasts into central and
southern parts of the country
that'll take a while to burn off first
thing in the morning uh also
early mist and fog has been affecting
many inland areas too
so it may be a rather grey start to the
day but we will see some sunshine coming
through
the best temperatures yesterday were the
western highlands and today there could
well be
a zone really from north west london up
through the midlands
to manchester and liverpool and again
the highlands here we could see 24 25
degrees celsius that would be 77 degrees
fahrenheit but to be honest with very
light winds
you don't need those really high
temperatures for it to feel really nice
and warm
however where we see that low cloud
hanging around those eastern coasts it
will be chilly yesterday eastern
scotland only eight or nine degrees
celsius
hopefully better there today but again
some of those eastern coast could be a
little bit
dull at times mostly fine for this
evening and overnight
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's have a look at the papers now with
us this morning the political journalist
dean bachelor hunt and broadcaster dj
and columnist
neve spencer hello again to you both
thanks again for coming back
um let's kick off with the guardian
nadine you've chosen this story
um what is this about combustible
insulation being put on schools
after grenfell yeah so this story is
about um
as you say combustible engineering being
put in schools postgraduate
file and the the the kind of the
cladding that's been put on
it was banned or you know it was banned
from high-rise apartment blocks
but it's being used on schools and it's
not just um schools so it says 70
schools here
are known to have the cladding but i
think it says like 25 recently built
hospitals
care homes and sheltered houses and
boxes and it's just another
disturbing chapter in the kind of
cladding fiasco post-gram file
and you know earlier this month there
was a fire um on
on a block of flats in london that had i
think 22 percent uh for padding now was
the same padding that was on grenfell
so a lot of the promises that have been
made about making housing
and and you know buildings more safer
opposed grandfather with that sort of
cladding just haven't been
um honored really and it's quite it's
quite shocking does anyone explain
how or why this has happened
um so it the schools were approached for
comment and
um so once one of the westminster was
approached for comment and they refused
to say
um but it's difficult to see regardless
of what i said how it's justifiable
particularly when you're putting on
schools where kids are
and you know we know this stuff is
dangerous it also releases like toxic
fumes i remember rightly so yeah
it's it's a bit yeah it's very it's very
concerning i think the association for
school
and college leaders also said it's a
major cause for concern
okay on to the sun need this is your
story um an exhibition has
been signed off by the queen an
exhibition of what
an exhibition of the duke's treasured
artifacts now this was actually planned
for the duke centenary which
of course didn't happen which is really
rather sad um and it's basically a
celebration
of his life their 73-year marriage
together
and it is set to take place at windsor
castle but the queen will not be
opening the exhibition that's been made
quite clear
and yes it is a celebration of his
family life
his naval career their incredible
and beautiful wedding and um royal
tourism actually has taken a massive hit
now this is a huge
thing people love to visit the castles
and normally
you know this is something that
generates millions but because of the
pandemic that hasn't happened and
so many jobs have been cut as well so
the hope is that this will bring a lot
of the public back in
obviously safely and generate some
all-important money
do they say when it's going to open
i'm not entirely sure actually i don't
think that they do i believe
it's soon but i'm not exactly sure
and that the queen will be offered a
private uh that's good of them seeing as
it's in her castle
um nadine to you now um tell us why
tenants
fear eviction this is page two of the
times
yeah so um a law and that was introduced
one point uh protect tenants from
eviction during the the pandemic because
it is kind of winding down
um and the joseph rowentry foundation is
saying that 400 000 families have
already been
served with an eviction notice and
another eight um more than eight hundred
thousand households renting
and now worried about being evicted and
you know it this could also
almost turn into a kind of renting
eviction pandemic or epidemic
um you know a lot of people lost money
during the pandemic lost jobs
and the eviction bans or you know or
limitations on evictions protected them
and now that's coming to a close
i it's like you're going to see a new
wave of homelessness and addiction so it
is quite concerning and i think
it's another one of those parts of the
of society that are suffering
whether or not the virus is in remission
or not it's going to suffer
beyond the end of the pandemic but this
is something that we've been following
here this morning
400 000 families are expecting to be
evicted
400 000 families what's going to happen
to them
well this is the thing we've already had
a huge homeless problem in the uk
before the pandemic i think in 2019 over
700 homeless people
died and so this is this is going to
just add to a problem
the government in my view aren't
spending enough money on protecting
homeless people
protecting rough sleepers it's a very
very um dire situation out there you
know we are recovering from a huge
recession we are bouncing back
more quickly than people expected but
that's going to be small comfort to
people that are about to be kicked out
of their homes
that's really really worrying um dean
let's leave that there neve
uh the telegraph who's been writing
about my life
yo-yo diets and sleep problems
this is exactly my life as well i've
been a yo-yo dieter
my entire life and then you wonder why
you can't sleep
the impact that yo-yo dieting which is
also known as weight cycling which is
really just
gaining and losing 10 pounds on and off
on and off on and off
is significantly serious it causes
heart disease stroke and other serious
health issues
and just gives terrible terrible sleep
the duration of your sleep is affected
your ability to fall asleep is affected
and you get disturbed more i mean i
would toddler
and before you i don't sleep anyway what
is sleep
but put into them
but it's um the new research is showing
that obviously this is a really serious
thing for women
and it's something that they're
investigating more but from what we
understand
it's connected with your gut so we know
that your gut
and your brain are connected so even
though you may switch off in your brain
through meditation or whatever putting
your phone away
your gut doesn't necessarily switch off
and that's what can wake you in the
night
hormones metabolism get affected this is
a really serious thing for women
yeah it really is we joke but it really
is um
okay nadine this is a cute little story
well it didn't start well but it ended
well
the guardian about a dog
yeah so a dog that was um left for dead
um and some rocks was found by some
welfare officers and
the injuries on the dog were quite sick
there had us as and several skull and
jaw fractures and was left winded in one
eye
um but he was taken care of operated on
i think his eye had to be removed from
the end
but um one of the rescuers adopted him
and now they're taking him in and they
say they can't imagine what life would
be without him
and yeah it's really really sweet i've
got some dogs at my mom's and it's
they are adorable they are really man
and woman's best friend
you